Speaker 1: All right. Listen, I don't believe
that at this time Ron DeSantis has a path to
the Republican nomination until something
changes. Unless something changes. But.
The numbers can't be denied. This is not a show
where I would ever try to deny the numbers.
Speaker 2: Thank your lucky stars
every day. You're not de facto.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, but I'm not going
to deny the numbers. Alex, please. Since news
of Ron DeSantis presidential announcement broke.
Desantis's polling is up 15%, while Donald Trump's
polling is down 5%. Now, I hate that I have to do
this, but I need to just do my disclaimer about
the difference between percent and percentage
points. If you go from 10 to 15%, you start
at 10%, you go to 15%. That's an increase of five
points, but it is an increase of 50%. Okay. You've
gained five and you started at ten. That is a 50%
increase, but a five point increase. Understanding
this mathematical nuance and looking at average
polling, we see that Donald Trump peaked at 56.3
and is now down since the Santos announcement
to 53.2. That's a decline of close to 6%. We'll
call it 5%. Similarly, DeSantis bottomed at 19.4
just before his announcement and has now climbed
to 22.4. That's an increase of a little more than
15%. Now, is this an inflection point? Which in
three months we will look at and Trump will be
down to 30 and DeSantis will be up to 50 maybe?
Or is this a short burst for DeSantis and a short
decline for Trump? Because the Santos has been
getting way more media attention lately than Trump
has? We just don't know yet. If we want to ask a
question that might inform us about polling. It's
May 31st, but we'll call it the beginning of June.
What we might ask is historically, how accurate
are primary polls on June 1st of the year before
the election? So, for example, like in 2016, what
was the polling like June 1st of 2015? We actually
have that data. Let's put it up on the screen.
If we look at 2016. In June of 2015, Jeb Bush
was leading by January of 2016. Trump had taken
the lead and Trump ultimately won. So in 2016,
the leader on June 1st was not indicative of
the eventual winner. In 2012, Mitt Romney was
leading. June of 2011, Newt Gingrich was leading
by January 1st, but Mitt Romney ended up being
the nominee. So in 2012, the June 1st polling
was indicative of the eventual winner, but it
changed. If we look at the Democratic primaries,
the Democratic primary of 2008. You see that while
Hillary was leading in June of 2007 and in January
of 2008, of course, ultimately it was Barack Obama
who won that nomination. Obama now and also
similarly in 2008, in the Republican primary,
a June of the year before Rudy Giuliani was
winning, By June 1st, Mike Huckabee had taken
the lead, but John McCain ultimately won that
primary. And we'll look at a couple others. In 24,
June of 23, it was Joe Lieberman. January of
24. Howard Dean had taken the lead. Of course,
the Dean scream. We're going to Iowa earlier,
ultimately tank this campaign. John Kerry,
the eventual winner of that primary. And then
lastly, in the year 2000, it was Al Gore in June.
Al Gore in January and Al Gore as the eventual
winner. So the answer is often the leader in June
of the year before does not end up being the
nominee. That being said, usually the leader
in the year before is not a former president,
which Donald Trump happens to be. So we are
going to follow it. But in the last ten days or
so, a significant gain for DeSantis of about 15%